the cabinets is a meeting later this
morning and it could be quite an
occasion following reports of widespread
unhappiness with the Prime Minister's
decision to delay the next meaningful
vote on brexit meanwhile the Labour
leader Jeremy Corbyn has said he is
prepared to back a second EU referendum
if it means preventing a damaging Tory
brexit well who to speak to about this
the shadow brexit secretary Sookie
Astana
joins us now from Westminster secured
very good morning to you it does strike
me that this second referendum at least
being an option more than simply being
on the table this has been something
you've been pushing for quite some time
do you think it's a vindication of the
this sounds that you've taken on this
it's a reflection I think of the motion
that we passed at our conference back in
September because what we were trying to
do then was to anticipate the decisions
we would have to make and agree what we
would do at each scenario and that's why
we set out the conditions that we would
need to support a deal that we would
call for a general election if the deal
didn't get through but that if that
didn't happen the option of a public
votes ought to be available and so we're
implementing if you like the third phase
of this we do I mean we do it because
the Prime Minister has dogged lis stuck
to her red lines notwithstanding all
their problems and is I think really
running down the clock I don't think
anybody thinks she's gonna get any
changes to her deal she's going to put
basically the same proposition to
Parliament up against No Deal she's
gonna do that on the 12th of March with
just 17 days to go
we the Labour Party have said repeatedly
that we don't accept her red lines or No
Deal so this reflects I think where
we've got to we will this week put down
our alternative plan which is for a
customs union and single market
alignment that's what we set out in the
letter to the Prime Minister
three weeks ago she's no inclination to
engage with that if that doesn't get
through that we will either ourselves
put down an amendment or support an
amendment in favour of a public vote to
prevent a brexit on the Prime Minister's
red lines or worse no deal and what
would be the options on that ballot
paper being put to the public in the
event of your deal being rejected
that the basic choice needs to be
between a credible leave option and
remain and so that means that if the
Prime Minister gets a deal through that
should be subject to the lock if you
like of a public vote so nor deal would
not be an option on that particular
ballot paper no it wouldn't and we've
said for a long time that no deal would
be disastrous for the country pretty
well every business says that and I've
talked businesses in England Wales
Scotland and Northern Ireland the Prime
Minister is I think today or tomorrow
going to publish her impact assessment
of No Deal and I expect that will show
just how bad it would be and I think
that we've got a responsibility to
protect our country from that outcome
and whatever people say now and I do
realize there are strong views on this
nobody is going to come to us and thank
us in months or years to come when their
job their business and their community
is suffering as a result of our failure
to protect the country against no deal
in what way though is this not the
Labour Party's Nick Clegg tuition fees
moment the 2017 manifesto was pretty
clear on this there are MPs within the
party like John man who chosen not to
leave but stay stay and fight with you
who suggest this is a betrayal that
another vote certainly in terms the
terms that you describe where the Labour
Party one imagines would be campaigning
to remain within the European Union why
is that not a betrayal of the 17 point 4
million voters well it's very important
to appreciate precisely what commitments
we made in that manifesto you are
absolutely right to say there was a
commitment to respect the outcome of the
referendum and that is why we triggered
article 50 that was a different change
amazing.just and you expect is the
result of distress just please you've
asked me a question let me at least
answer it then you can quiz me as much
you like on it but we made a commitment
to respect the outcome of the referendum
we triggered article 50 which was not
easy for the Labour Party on that basis
but we also made a commitment that we
would not accept their prime minister's
red lines or a deal along those lines
and that we would do all that we
to prevent No Deal now we've got to the
stage where we're presented with the
Prime Minister's red lines or No Deal a
manifesto said that we should take all
necessary steps to prevent that so we
have to face the situation where
actually in now at the end of the
two-year window on article 15 not the
beginning of the window on article 50
and we need to look at all of the
commitments we made in our manifesto
okay I do understand the logic of the of
the case that you're making there the
position that you point out at the same
time
surely you must also understand the
logic of those who voted to leave the
European Union that it is not the Labour
Party respecting the result of the
referendum if they then campaign in a
second one to remain within the EU but
that leaves out of account that leaves
out of account that for two years we
have been spelling out what a brexit
deal to leave should look like spelling
it out and challenging the prime
minister up hill and down dale that we
should have a customs union and single
market alignment we did that on the
basis of what businesses are telling us
we need we also did on the basis of
believing genuinely and I do that it's
the only credible way of protecting the
border situation in Northern Ireland the
Prime Minister's rejected that she's not
engaged in that she's now pushed it up
to the 11th hour saying it's my red
lines unchanged or No Deal
now with those situate in that situation
we will push our brexit deal again we'll
push that on Wednesday we do think
that's credible we do think it's capable
of being negotiated but if the Prime
Minister won't engage with it if she if
she she tries to vote it down we are
left then in the final days with this
choice between her deal on her all red
lines or no deal and the Labour Party is
committed to preventing that happening
so this has to be seen in its proper
context